amos isn't afraid of monsters she said
the words tasted bitter but not
completely so or no
not bitter complex though she is
responsible for a lot of dead people jim
said
she blew up to took out a quarter of the
crew
and that one body they found the one she
was carrying around in a toolbox do you
remember that
i do that guy was a friend of hers she
wasn't just killing faceless enemies
she was right down look them in the eyes
killing people that she knew that she
liked
how do you go from that to i know let's
ship with her
she knew she should stop him he wasn't
talking about her or the august and
gamora
or any of the other ships that had been
sabotaged since using the code she wrote
he wasn't talking about sin
or the way he tried to intervene in her
half-stage suicide
if he had been there would have been
more how could she abandon her son
how could she let philip think that
she'd killed herself how could she have
kept something that important hidden
from the people she said she cared about
all the sins she carried that even
clarissa mal
didn't hey guys pete here now that we've
had some time to reflect on season five
it's time to look at the biggest
questions we have
heading into season six as for spoilers
there will be a lot if you haven't
watched all the available episodes of
the expanse through season 5.
i'll be referring to the books the
series is based on but nothing past the
fifth one
nemesis games so there won't be any
future spoilers there
with that out of the way let's talk
about season six
one of the questions i've seen the most
is who will be the new pilot on the
rossi now that alex is dead
i'll circle back and talk about his
death and how that affects the story a
little more at the
end of the video but as far as his
replacement i think
it will probably be bull mainly because
i don't know why they would add the
scene of him sitting in the captain's
chair
holding alex's mug otherwise the shot
serves no purpose other than to hint
that he's the new pilot for the rossi
the other two named characters who've
been candidates for the role were bobby
and clarissa
bobby has done some piloting the ship
sort of needs a martian on it now
and she's definitely a popular character
however the thing with her being the
pilot is it takes away
any chances of her being a marine if
she's flying it
she can't defend the ship and she can't
do any of the other things that bobby is
good at
either think about the things alex did
he sat and he waited for the crew to
come back so he could fly them away
clarissa has some piloting in her
background too but i think she makes
even less sense overall
don't get me wrong i see why people like
this idea i see it a lot in the comments
and i guess she has the most potential
to develop into the same role that alex
played in the crew dynamic but even
though she's bonded with amos
and the crew definitely trust him i
can't imagine that they trust her yet
she did try to kill holden
she did try to kill them she had a turn
she made up for it in some ways
but in season five we had this whole
thing where everybody realized this is
their family this is their home
would it make sense that they would hand
over such a crucial role
to clarissa as far as bull is concerned
i didn't like the idea of him being
pilot at first
mainly because he's not the same type of
character as alex with more thought
though
all that really means is that things
will be different within the crew
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
the authors of the books
are writers on the show and i tend to
believe that they're capable of
incorporating this change of personnel
in a satisfying way
the next question then is will bobby and
clarissa join the crew
what about monica it seemed like she was
trying to keep herself close to the
action in the finale
i think it's safe to say that with bobby
being announced as avasarala's liaison
that she'll play a large role
in the sixth season and considering that
it seems like everything's set up for
there to be a war between
the inners and the free navy you would
imagine that she might find herself on
the rossi
as far as clarissa she doesn't really
have anywhere else to go
in the books during their journey amos
and clarissa make a pact that if she has
to go back to earth
has to go back to prison to serve her
sentence he'll actually kill her
she'd rather die than go back and i
doubt that the show would change that
even though it wasn't explicitly stated
in other words it looks like she would
probably be on the ship throughout
season six
monica is a question mark they upped her
role somewhat in season five i think
most people i've talked to
seem to like that they thought it was a
good idea to have her there with holden
at least while
naomi's gone so we'll have to wait and
see i think she will be involved with
the story for sure but i don't know if
that'll involve
being a passenger on the ross ante or
not
the next thing that i got a lot of
questions about was will the breakaway
martian fleet play a big role in the
final season
this is an area where show watchers and
book readers
are wondering the same thing for
different reasons joe people are
wondering what their plan is
and book readers already know that so
they're wondering if this changes things
and i lean towards no the laconians gave
us an idea of their vision
and that's not something that can happen
overnight for those who are wondering
what happened to the bar
keith i do think we'll learn a lot more
about that in season six even if it's
unrelated to laconia
if you're wondering why they were
introduced at the end of season five if
they're not going to play a big role
well they had to be the end of season
five was almost a direct adaptation of
the epilogue of the fifth book
and it has to be there because there's a
lot of stuff that wouldn't make sense
otherwise
such as how did marco get his fleet in
the first place
why did he want to control the ring
network why did he want to steal the
protomolecule and so on
all of marco's actions were coordinated
with these people
and so we did have to meet them but now
that he controls medina station and the
ring space
that actually puts them completely out
of the inner planet's reach
soviet himself actually outlined this in
the second episode
when he was talking about how the ring
space was an asymmetrical choke point
right now that part of the martian fleet
that made it through laconia gate
aren't the first order of business and
speaking of earth and mars
how bad are things they haven't made it
clear how many people
were involved in this martian breakaway
fleet we're just gonna have to wait and
see what happens
at the beginning of next season for that
as far as earth is concerned
one of the big questions that people
have been asking is how bad
is it how much damage did the asteroid
attacks have
this has been an ongoing question for
book readers because it seemed like the
show downplayed it a bit
beyond what we saw throughout the season
the most detailed description i've seen
comes from a post-finale interview with
one of the series co-creators ty
frank the question was framed as are all
the major cities in the world
in as bad as shape as baltimore is he
answered
no they're not there have only been
three asteroid strikes the cities that
are devastated the same way
baltimore is one of the ones that are
close to the strikes
but there is still widespread problems
in other cities
even the ones that weren't directly hit
problems with access to food access to
power
so there's a breakdown in the social
structures and the civil structures
but not all the cities have physically
collapsed
so to me that sounds like we can expect
that there will be major problems on the
planet but it's still not really clear
how devastating it'll be so i already
kind of mentioned
why marco wanted to control the ring
gates in the first place this was part
of the martian plan
but another question i got was more
specific towards belters
in that why would he want to control the
transit when belters can't live on the
planets anyways
and there's a couple options here he
could just shut it down
not let anybody travel anywhere that
would keep the status quo
at least as far as resource extraction
inside the system
if the free navy were running things you
would have to think that belters would
get a better deal
the other option is what fred johnson
wanted to do in the first place it was
control medina station
so that he had a part in what happened
in the system
and therefore was too powerful to
displace or just
ignore it was a good idea marco could
pick that up
and he actually has a navy to go along
with medina so he would be in a lot more
powerful of a situation
another question out there and one i'm
really interested in myself
is what's going to happen with drummer
the last time we saw her
her family split apart it was just her
on the time in with joseph and michio
there's not a lot of good options for
her in this situation
there's an outside chance that oxana
could make a plea towards marco
saying that she didn't have anything to
do with the betrayal
which is true but you would think that
marco would definitely go after drummer
and even if he doesn't his influence
will be felt
almost anywhere she goes she wouldn't be
able to interact with any belter ships
because she wouldn't know if they were
sympathetic to the free navy
and what's more just as he took over
medina station
strategically he should work to try to
take over the other stations
so there's really no safe place for her
to go even after palace's attack
it still wouldn't make sense that all
belters followed
marco blindly with fred gone at tycho
there is the possibility that drummer
might step into that void
take over his role or if not that you
think she would have to reach out to the
ross ante
to holden and to naomi because there's
really nowhere else for her to go
so i'm curious to see where they go with
it
so i did get a lot of questions about
alex about what his death means for the
rest of the story
a lot of questions about whether he died
in the book if he died in the book in
the same way
what are we gonna miss out on if he's
not there as far as the decision to kill
him off i look at that as they didn't
really have a better option
if you look into it at all and there is
a really comprehensive
thread on the subreddit which i'll put a
link to in the comments if you haven't
seen it
if you look into everything that's out
there there was really no scenario where
this actor came back to play this
character again
so did alex die in the book no he didn't
so he didn't die in the same way the
character that did die this way from a
high g maneuver
was fred johnson but that didn't happen
until book six
they decided to kill fred off early in
the season
because according to the writers they
wanted there to be some stakes involved
because a lot of crazy stuff happens
and nobody really dies in the narrative
and i tend to agree with this to a
certain extent
because the first time i read the books
i read straight through one through
six those were already out by the time
that i started reading it and they're
page turners so i just read through them
all
and was basically in binge mode and it
was around this time in book five where
i started to think this is a fun story i
like everything about it but there
aren't really any stakes because i never
feel like any of the main characters
could die
so to me it looks like they killed fred
early and that left the original way he
died
out there they found out about the
allegations about casanbar the studio
did an investigation that lasted a
couple months
and they decided to fire him after
season five was already shot
so they had to do something and in my
opinion this is the best thing that you
could come up with
i was never a big fan of recasting
because
original alex already had such a good
chemistry you had five
seasons of it so i think it's better
that you just don't even try to recreate
that you just go a different way
you have the original writers involved
let them come up with something
don't try to give us a watered-down
version of something that already worked
as far as the character is concerned i
think this is a fitting death with him
now that doesn't mean that i think it
came off flawlessly
like i said it feels pretty obvious that
this wasn't the original
ending of the season like i always do
when i finish watching an episode on
amazon prime i went straight into the
bonus content and right after the show
aired he was in all the photos on luna
they hadn't edited him out like they did
in the episode
and so yeah that sucks it would have
been nice if none of this had happened
like we could just have things the way
they were
originally intended but that's just not
the case and so i think that giving alex
a hero's ending that fits with what the
character would want
amos laid this out perfectly in the
finale that's really just the best you
could hope for
as far as what we might miss without
alex the only significant thing he did
in book six
other than just being the pilot was he
got into a side romance
so personally i won't miss that all that
much and he did have some great moments
in later books but
we don't even know if we're gonna get to
see those stories yet or not so
what are you gonna do if you thought
that killing off a major character in a
high g
burn was less than thrilling i kind of
understand when i first read fred's
death it took a while to set in
based on how it happened i was like fred
is really dead he just died in the chair
during the battle
why didn't anyone notice any of that you
know but with time it grew on me
because it underlines the fact that it
could happen to anyone at any time
it's the same thing they say high g
maneuvers are dangerous
yet no one ever gets hurt or suffers the
consequences
after a while it starts to feel like
there aren't any stakes and i think
that's a good place to leave it
let me know in the comments what
questions you have about season six
i'll try to answer what i can i don't
usually do live streams
but i was thinking maybe about doing one
discuss and answer some questions about
seasons five and six
and bring on a couple other youtubers so
let me know what you think about that
idea
also i have heard the request about the
laconia book spoilers
so i've been working on that i'm trying
to put together something that gives
backstory and details without ruining
the future plot points
because you really should read the books
and experience those as they were
intended for yourself please like this
video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon